-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, after teasing
a name change for a while, now,
today Mark Zuckerberg
finally revealed
the new name of Facebook.
Here it is.
-To reflect who we are
and what we hope to build,
I am proud to announce that,
starting today,
our company is now...
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Yeah.
-Meta?
-Meta.
-What?
-Yeah.
Meta, as in,
"When I joined Facebook,
I Meta [met a] lot
of crazy people."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey!
-Thank you.
[ Rimshot ]
-Yeah!
Wow, baby!
-Yeah, Facebook
changed their name
and the response spectrum
was like --
[ Smoker's gravelly voice ]
We used to be TimeWarner
and people still hate us.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This feels like
when there's an E. coli outbreak
at a pizza place
and they just change the name
from Sal & Tony's
to Tony & Sal's.
[ Laughter ]
Same grass owners, yeah.
Companies often
change their name
to help their image
and, since it's up for grabs,
Johnson & Johnson is now
Facebook & Facebook.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They'll take it.
Meta.
Yeah, Meta.
Apparently, they're trying
to win back younger users.
They even released a new ad
and it seems like they're trying
a little too hard
to get to young --
You be the judge.
-What up, fam?!
You want a dope
social media network
that's so snatched?!
Then join Facebook.
-F-F-F-Facebook!
-We're totally bussin'
with Russian memes.
And we got a hella fire CEO.
[ Roars ]
We're not cheugy.
We're the GOAT.
-[ Screeching ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Wow!
-"What up, fam?!"
[ Laughter ]
Some news
from the White House --
coming off some of his lowest
approval rating numbers,
today President Biden left
for Europe
and his first stop is in Rome,
where he's going to meet
with Pope Francis.
Now, however,
the Vatican just canceled
the live broadcast
of the two of them meeting.
Not a great time for Biden,
when the Pope is like,
"I can't be seen with you
right now."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, since Biden is going
to be out of town for Halloween,
the White House
will not be holding
its usual
trick-or-treating event.
[ Audience awws ]
Smart move, though, to announce
to the entire country
that you're going to be
out of town on Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
"How far do you think
I can throw this egg?
Hit the West Wing
from here, you think?"
[ Laughter ]
If there's another
toilet paper shortage,
you can find it in all the trees
around the White House.
[ Laughter ]
Biden actually wanted
to do trick-or-treating,
but Joe Manchin blocked it
because he hates
government handouts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Come on!
[ Rimshot ]
Come on!
-That's right,
no Halloween at the White House,
meanwhile, one very
nervous bird was like,
"He's still doing the turkey
pardoning next month, right?
[ Laughter ]
Hi, I'm Giblet, by the way."
"I'm Wishbone, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
In a couple weeks,
it's going to be like
Red Light, Green Light
with us, so."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
While talking to reporters,
Senator Bernie Sanders
was interrupted
by a phone call
and people were talking
about his loud ringtone.
Listen to this.
-So you're not onboard with this
framework, as it's now drafted?
[ Ring ]
-I want to see the language.
I want to see it improved.
[ Ring ]
And again, I think it --
you know.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's actually
not an old-timey ringtone.
He actually has a rotary phone
in his pocket.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Sanders ] I can only go
60 feet from my house
before the --
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, he picked up the phone
by putting a horn in his ear.
[ As Sanders ]
Hello! What?!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is cool --
Delta Airlines
is launching a new program
that will use facial recognition
for passengers going
through TSA.
It's all part
of Delta's brilliant plan
to get people to take
their masks off at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
They actually had the same
facial recognition program
before you board a plane
on Southwest Airlines.
Check this out.
-[ Speaking Korean ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
Yeah, they don't mess around
on Southwest, yeah.
[ Applause ]
They don't mess around.
[ Cheering ]
Some more travel news.
This is real.
United Airlines just announced
that, next month,
it will begin selling
mini bottles of hard liquor
on flights.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah, the move is all part
of the company's new slogan...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-[ Slurring ] I'll just have
one more.
I'll just have one more.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that
a futuristic robot dog
was just spotted walking
down 6th Avenue here
in New York City.
Watch this video, yeah.
-[ Barks ]
-Yeah. Even crazier, there was
another robot walking behind it
with a little plastic bag.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-I love how New Yorkers
walked by
like nothing was happening,
like, "Oh, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
The robot was like --
[ As Schwarzenegger ]
I'm a cybernetic organism sent
from the future
to pee on fire hydrants.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They're like, "Oh, that?
That's normal. No big deal."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, this isn't good --
a new study shows small amounts
of plastic are found
in the food from chains
like McDonald's.
[ Murmuring ]
You can tell things are bad
at McDonald's.
Today, they changed their name
to McMeta.
[ Laughter and applause ]